what if he doesn't survive he's worth a
lot to me
put captain solo in the cargo hold as
you wish
he's no good to me dead nope
nope uh
beaufette does not have any iconic lines
from the original trilogy
in fact i think i actually just said
every line he ever had
[Music]
hey there folks haven't done a review
for anything other than doctor who here
on the main channel for a while and this
might not be the start of a new trend
i'm rolling the dice seeing how this
does uh if the numbers are there maybe
these will continue to appear here as a
wednesday feature uh if they do more
middling numbers this will probably
transfer over to the break room of geeks
subscribe over there if you haven't
already that's where most of my review
material goes these days but you know
what i feel like rolling the dice let's
try it it's almost a new year i was
gonna say we're in a new year try new
things it's not yet it's close but it's
not
anyways book of boba fett
let me jump to the end a little bit
i like this a lot
which is
relieving
in a way because like look i love star
wars
i literally grew up on star wars i do
not remember seeing any of the original
trilogy for the first time
they've always just been there
that's my relationship with this
franchise i've always loved it
but
that having been said
there isn't a lot outside of that
original trilogy that i have a lot of
deep love for i could never get into the
expanded universe before it became star
wars legends some of the video games
were okay never got into the novels or
any of that sort of thing the prequel
trilogy was
i didn't like it um up until revenge of
the sith which i do like the disney
trilogy started out strong
frustrated me but in an interesting way
with the last jedi which i didn't like
but like it's not uninteresting and then
frustrated me in a very boring way with
rise of skywalker
and even just looking at the tv output
mandalorian is
fine
i like the vibe of the mandalorian and i
appreciate what it's doing
more than i actually enjoy it i don't
think it's bad i'm just not overly
impressed by it i gave up on bad batch
after three episodes because i just i
didn't care
and star wars visions just annoyed the
ever loving crap out of me
now i know
i know
that in a lot of these cases i'm in a
minority and a lot of star wars fans
have enjoyed some or all well not rise
of skywalker but you know many of the
things that i've said i haven't enjoyed
and that's fine that doesn't make you
any more of a fan than me this is not
any kind of lightsaber measuring contest
we've got going on here
my point is
it's been a long time
since i saw something star wars related
that made me just go oh
i definitely want to watch more of this
the mandalorian like made me go okay i
guess i'll keep watching this is much
stronger than that
and it's
hard for me to nail down exactly why
this is working so much better for me
than the mandalorian i think largely
because it's not a singular clear thing
it's a ton of little things i did a
review of the very first episode of the
mandalorian and i nitpicked it like nuts
and not to be a buzzkill but because
tons of tiny little details were driving
me nuts because of the way they did it
or what they chose to do
none of that's in play here
i think it was actually to their benefit
to actually just set it in a flat out
familiar setting of tatooine and jabba's
palace and the immediate surrounding
area as opposed to something that is
technically a new place but is
incredibly reminiscent of that like
jakku was in the disney trilogy so
i feel like things like that just owning
the fact
that we are just going to dip into old
stuff and old characters that you like
but we're going to do some new stuff
with them and honestly boba fett
is a great character to do this with
not because boba fett's an amazing
character let's be honest he's not he
looked really cool in the original
trilogy absolutely great design good
presence he was shot well i prefer the
original more raspy voice that the guy
had but you know the dubbed in voice
that worked it that worked well enough
but
he wasn't really characterized he wasn't
really a character
he was a really cool stan d that was in
a lot of shots but he wasn't much of a
character
so he's actually someone who you can
expand on
and give us more of
and it doesn't feel like well that
doesn't feel right the way that it might
when you start
messing more with characters like
the past of han solo or the future of
luke skywalker regardless of what you
think of either of those times that
they've done that
you have to admit that's a lot more
fraught
because people have very clear ideas of
what they think those characters are i'm
sure there are people who have read tons
of boba fett material in expanded
universe whatevers who have a better
sense of boba fett as a character but as
someone who has a very deep love of the
original trilogy but has not dived into
any of the rest of that because it just
doesn't appeal to me in that respect i
think i represent a lot bigger
proportion of the audience not that that
again that's not a superiority thing
just realistically
you can give us more of this guy you can
start to show us who he is and i feel
like i there was like one thing that i
was wavering on just a little bit but
they found a great way to sell it like
at the very end of the episode
um i'm gonna talk pretty freely about
the plot at this point so there will be
some spoilers
if you're uh watching out for that i
like this a lot the characters are well
performed it's really well shot for the
most part there's one scene at night
like okay seriously if you're making
something for streaming stop shooting it
in the kind of dark load light that only
works in a movie theater where the only
light source is the screen i'm watching
this in a room and i've got ambient
daylight coming and i can barely see
what the hell is going on stop it stop
that
but other than that one nighttime bit
really well shot really well done good
tension good action good progression
good use of flashbacks and the points at
which it cuts back to modern uh well
modern for the character uh current
timeline and the mechanism used to do
that feels really good
i really want to see where this goes
from here i'm intrigued by these
characters i still feel like boba fett
himself is not the most compelling in
terms of when he actually starts talking
i'll get to that it is one of my little
nitpicks about this um but it does help
that he's right next to ming na wen who
boy does she command the screen holy
crap but she manages to do it in a way
that doesn't take away from she's not
sucking the the oxygen out of the room
but she is upping the ambient energy of
the room so
they're a good pairing it's working
really well for me so far and i dig the
premise i dig the sense of where i think
it's going
i want to see more
okay so getting into some more specifics
i
well first of all
they did a real good job of making the
inside of that starlight look
horrifying
oh
crap
and i also like the idea that boba fett
gets out but he doesn't get out by being
like badass and he gets out of like uh
i'm free no he gets out and passes out
and gets all of his stuff stolen
by the freaking jawas
and then tuscans show up and they're
like oh
free labor
he's still alive we can put him to work
and then he has to deal with that it
really is emphasizing he's not like the
most amazing guy he's just gonna badass
his way through everything no he's
resilient he's resourceful but he's also
getting the crap kicked out of him
across this which helps a lot because
kind of
the image of boba fett in the collective
fan unconsciousness is this
real badass and i'm like he's never
really done much to earn that title
again great look but we don't actually
see him get into combat in the original
trilogy like at all and the one time he
briefly does it's very short-lived
before he ends up in that pit
um oh tiny side note about the sorry
like i appreciate that they shot it from
such an angle that we don't see the beak
but not such an angle where it's like oh
we're retconning and the sarlacc doesn't
have the beak but anymore no it's just
an angle where no we're not going to
show you that
as someone who thought the beak was a
dumb addition thank you
thank you you're not erasing it for
anybody who likes it but i don't have to
see it that's great i love that
uh i mentioned having one nitpick about
uh
him when he speaks it's not when he's
interacting with mignon when in the
present-day setting it is
in the like honestly
i don't understand why there's a single
word of spoken dialect with spoken
english dialogue in the flashback at all
i really don't
because there is nothing that he
communicates that is not in evidence
just by watching what's going on i think
it would have been more compelling
to just
watch him
deal with the situation the way he does
without having to
say it out loud
you want me to dig
for water like yeah no i yeah
i saw that just do it and they didn't
when the bits where he talked they
didn't kill
anything but like didn't need to be
there i think it would have been way
more badass if he just had kept his
mouth shut
um that said though when he's actually
having dialogue with characters works
better now i mentioned the one thing
that like i was wavering on but the very
end really sold me on so
i was a little bit
on this whole idea that we were getting
early on where we're seeing him in
jabba's palace we're seeing him you know
having mercy for some guards who would
work for jabba previously
where overall he's got this whole thing
of i don't want people to fear me i want
them to respect me and they seem to have
him with this sort of honor code and i
was debating that i'm like
again that feels like a projection of
what fans wanted out of the character
and again maybe it's something that is
more representative of non-film uh
material that most of which is non-canon
now
like
don't forget that but
it's one of those things i'm like yeah
but
is he though is he this kind of
honorable guy
because you know he's
he has to be told don't disintegrate
your target who has done nothing for you
you're just supposed to bring him for a
bounty like he's just gonna do whatever
works was the impression i always got
from him
but they use the flashback really well
and they show
that what him that what got him out of
that situation
with the tuscan raiders
dealing with that multi-armed thing
which i didn't like the face on that but
again that's net picky when he helped
kill that thing
that was when he was able to get out of
that situation
he couldn't get out sneakily he couldn't
make them afraid of him
but once they respected him
that was what not only got him out but
got him help
so
i can now buy even if prior to the
events of this he was a bit more
cutthroat a bit more ruthless i see that
moment and how well it was executed and
how intense i've had to watch him go
through all this stuff crawling out of
the starlight getting his stuff stolen
get getting tied to rocks trying to
escape failing all of this stuff and i'm
like
anything that gets you out of that
situation yeah
yeah i could see him latching on to them
being like this is this is the way to go
about things and it's clear that what
got him out of that was earning respect
and so now the stuff that was going on
in the present day i was like i don't
know if i buy this from this character
give me that moment i'm like oh
now i do
now i do
this
is really smartly constructed
and a lot of the stuff that annoyed me
about the mandalorian were bits that
felt like they were only there for no
reason other than to make fans go oh
and occasionally it worked but it it
felt so manipulative to me it felt so
there's no reason to do this other than
to get that ooh
and there were things in this that gave
me that little
but they felt like they would have been
there even if they weren't going to get
that reaction these the the things that
are fanservicey feel organic as opposed
to uh injected in
for no reason other than fan service
this is
way tighter this is way more focused
this is way more interested in telling a
story than just giving me good vibes
which was kind of what mandalorian left
me with like yeah it's good vibes i'm
not super invested in the story but yeah
good good
star wars e ronin kind of journey vibes
this i'm actually interested in this
story i want to see where the plot goes
in addition to liking the vibes
book of boba fett
this is a strong start i got a lot of
hope here
don't let me down
don't let me down again
i i it feels good to unabashedly really
like a star wars thing
i'd like to hold on to that please
please
but what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it i have
a patreon it's how i pay my bills also a
link down in the description links to
other things as well you know other
social medias my twitch channel
po box if you feel like sending anything
my way
hey
whatever but don't worry too much about
it
because
at the end of the day
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
none of this would have been possible
without my supporters over on patreon in
particular i want to thank robin powell
raven mcbain tracy scrabbit vincent paul
bartolucci robin moore and shayla
gourley if you'd like to hear me
possibly mispronounce your name maybe
consider looking at the reward tears
over on the patreon
but either way don't worry about it too
much take care of yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]